Rinkyu wa rai-chan
is a total move Cheek
Usamura
Who's permission are you trying to take out that panel
Put it on a scaffold Oh yeah yeah
yeah
Shima City Rikichi No. The
car is heading for the city The
car is a company rv It's
moving toward the edge where the Kendo Okappakan is located I don't
think I can cross my legs, so tell the police
Abel
Weapons are kappa  I'm in the same class aiming for the direction of the column Good luck
Hey,
what should I do 3, but if I get arrested, I
'll get on the highway with our prince and abandon the car at an unfair place and run away Yeah,
ah ah ah ah
good  Hey, I might have hit the
wrong person with the kit What
is a woman in a kimono and dried fish? Is that a ghost
?  Don't float away
[music]
Rear was
happening
anoano Line up It's
okay I wonder if it's okay
tar
menime I
thought I could escape  I
wonder if the enemy can't run away.